good morning believe nation today's
message is have the right people around
you over to you Chris Brown the main
thing I would say to somebody if they
ask me some some new artists that might
ask me for advice all right well don't
take my advice cuz I wanna show you the
wrong way to do it you know but at the
end of the day I tell you no just tell
them keep that circle really tight you
know make sure you got a lot of loyalty
right a lot of real people that I want
to see you be the best person you can be
not just for what can bring them you
know fame wealth or whatever it is you
know so I just make sure people got the
right team around you got people who who
are smart who are thinking about your
best interests all so this topic brings
two thoughts to mind for me the first is
you need to build a team as an
entrepreneur you need to have the right
people around you to help you do what
you're trying to do right you might need
a programmer you might need an
Operations first you might need a driver
you might need you know a whole bunch of
different people because you can't do
this business alone and the impact you
can have will be so much bigger if you
can build a team to help you achieve
that common mission that is a common
message I've talked a lot about on this
channel the second part of the have the
right people around you message though
that I took from Chris is you need to
have people in your life who push you to
be better and that often doesn't come
from your team it's not very often that
your employee will say hey you could be
doing a much better job I think you're
playing small right that doesn't usually
come from the people underneath you and
I think a lot of people don't have that
in their life and I think if I was
looking at back at my life it was one of
the things that I was missing most yes I
was having success as an entrepreneur
yes I was reaching a lot of milestones
and hitting my goals but I didn't have
people around me saying that I could do
better
I had supportive people I had people
saying great job why are you doing such
an amazing thing you're helping so many
people awesome and it's great to hear
but there wasn't anybody telling me
then you could do better and here's how
to go and do it and so my solution to
that because it didn't have that mentor
or that person in my life was to do the
top 10 videos to do the top 10 to the
mentor me to do the making it to the
live life where now I feel like I'm
hanging around these all-star
entrepreneurs and innovators every
single day and by seeing what they do
and how they think in the actions that
they're taking and being around them
consistently I feel like they've pushed
me to be better that they are my coach
that Howard Schultz is my coach and
Kanye West is my coach and Steve Jobs is
my coach and Oprah Winfrey is my coach
all of these people doing these great
things that we profile on the channel
every single day push me to be better to
be stronger to cut through my fear to
stop telling myself lies and BS excuses
why I can't do something and so why I
push so hard to do more to be better
because I know I can because I barely
scratched the surface of my potential
and by looking at these people have done
a lot more they helped me realize that I
could do a lot more too and I think
that's badly needed in everybody's life
for a lot of the people around me I am
that person in their life I am the
believe guy I am the guy who's saying
listen you're here but I know you could
be up here I believe in you here's how
to get there let me walk you through
that and so I think it's important that
you try to surround yourself with people
who had to start at least support you
right not the people who are negative
and telling you why it can't work and
being the little man in your life right
people who at least support you and are
encouraging but the next step is not
just the people who aren't encouraging
you but the people who are challenging
you to do more to be better to reach
further to go faster they go harder to
be bolder have those people in your life
and if you don't have it just like I
don't then use the videos or use books
or use interviews or whatever it is
because if you don't surround yourself
with those people who challenge you
consistently then you are going to play
small for the rest of your life so the
question that they today is do you have
the right people around
you and what do you do to stay
challenged leave in the comments below
I'm going to join in the discussion
thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day continue to believe or
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso